hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
one of the key features of arthur
schopenhauer's essay on the basis of
morality
is his identification
of three
fundamental
incentives treb feyden in german for
human actions these are you could say
the
overarching motives that yield to us all
the other
motives that in a more intermediary
sense are what are going to directly
lead to our actions in concrete
situations but these are sort of
overarching
everybody well hopefully everybody has
these everyone at least has the
potential for these
you know you could call them
metamotives whatever you want these are
the things that really drive us right
tribe is a drive by itself and so these
are fundamental sources you could also
say another translation for them
and he brings these up at several points
but he gives it the
furthest elaboration and application
within part three
because there he is developing
not a metaphysics but an ethics of
compassion by opposition
to these
anti-moral
motives or incentives which he's just
analyzed in a earlier
chapter of that and
he's going to bring up some things that
he's willing to call axioms he says i'll
mention a few premises
of you know the proof that i would give
that are the hypotheses of the argument
and may well be regarded as axioms and
what is an axiom it's something that you
take as a starting point
it might be unproven just asserted but
it's going to be fruitful for you to
follow it out and see where it goes the
two axioms that he discusses that are
most applicable and this is in
chapter 16 a statement and proof of the
only genuinely moral incentive where
he's going to actually talk about these
fundamental incentives so are three and
four
three runs
what moves the will is simply wheel and
woe in general and is taken in the
widest sense of the term just as
conversely wheel and woe signify in
agreement with or contrary to a will
hence every motive must have a reference
to wheel and whoa so that's the the
payoff there every
motive of the person that is acting must
have reference to wheel and wall in
general now there's two things to to say
here before we go on one is
that this is you know more or less in
accordance with
all sorts of understandings of the will
as being this kind of general faculty
that aims at
the good or avoids the bad in general
you know you can see this in thomas
aquinas just as much as you can see say
encounter people like that and everybody
in between
and another thing is a terminology so
the wheel that means goodness right
something good for you
vol in german and there's a lot of
compositions of vol in this book you
know
vol height you know attaining uh
goodness for a person and that's indeed
what egoism aims at in some respects
one's own
vol or let's call it goodness things
that are good for you right
wheel is an old-fashioned term for that
whoa
is another old-fashioned term uh you
know you may know the locution whoa is
me and when you say that you're saying
things suck for me
and the german for that is veya right
which
conveys more or less the same content
something that's not good something
that's bad for you something that's
harmful something that hurts you
and so um motives have reference to
wheel or woe
in general so it could be
your own or it could be
others and
the other thing that he says that's
particularly important here this is in
number four
every action refers to and has as its
ultimate object what it is directed
towards
a being
susceptible to wheel and wall so it's
not just
creating goodness creating badness it's
generating a state that is good or bad
or a feeling or however we want to frame
it
for a being and then we can move on and
look at these fundamental uh incentives
which he's going to talk about in just a
few pages
so
he says that
there are generally only three
fundamental incentives of human actions
and all possible motives operate solely
through their stimulation what are these
well there's egoism
egoismus which you know we'll talk about
in just a moment it's not just
a simple generic kind there's all sorts
of types of egoism
there is malice bose height literally
badness right or evil an evil
state and then there's compassion
mid-lied
and this is something absolutely central
for schopenhauer's ethics you're going
to see this term over and over and over
again throughout this work and
you know
schopenhauer is saying every human
action must be attributed to
one of these these are the fundamental
motivators for human beings this is
what gives us
the ways
in which we actually
make our choices the ways we
behave the ways we
prioritize even the ways we think about
what i ought to do or what i ought not
to do
so he tells us
every human action must be attributable
that is we can we can say aha this is
coming from this now i want to point out
schopenhauer is not saying that we're
all mind readers and that in every
single case of looking at another human
being or even at ourselves we
automatically
intuitively unequivocally know precisely
which of these three motives is going on
there's you know even within our own
life we can think that we're acting out
of compassion when really we're acting
out of
egoism you know for example we might be
protecting somebody from bullying by
going up to the bully and punching him
right you know in the face
that might actually be malice rather
than the compassion we tell ourselves
people can act in ways that you know we
think are compassionate and then we find
out no they were actually
gearing up for something helpful for
them the entire time
really a matter of egoism
and he also tells us that two of these
can
all also act in combination so you know
sometimes
we can have
actions that are
mixed in terms of motives the only good
part
of it morally speaking not you know
good good in the the full sense rather
than just being good for or something
like that is the the
motive or the incentive of compassion
the others one is actually anti-moral
the malice and
the other
is
amoral or you know lacking moral value
and those who have read emmanuel kant
his groundwork for the metaphysics of
morals will identify those three motifs
quite quite easily what is it that
egoism and malice and compassion are
about well he tells us here that egoism
desires
one's own will so the an egoistic
incentive or motive on the part of the
person who is acting not the person who
is passive
is
aimed at their own well-being and he
talks you know quite a bit about what
this looks like it includes
not just continuing in existence say
preserving one's own life but also
you know well-being
uh sort of a perfection of one's being
pleasure that can go along with it
avoiding
painfulness trouble stuff like that
those are fundamental
uh dimensions of that that incentive of
egoism what about malice i do want to
point out something else too here
he says that
um
for the purpose of easier comprehension
i've simplified the above derivation of
compassion
as the sole source of actions of moral
worth by intentionally leaving out of
account the incentive of malice like
compassion
this too
is without self-interest
and makes its ultimate aim the pain
of another so it's it's you know not
egoistic although it does spring out of
egoism if we look at the previous
chapter
what it desires is another's woe to do
damage to them to harm them to
see them humiliated reduced to nothing
perhaps even extinguished from
existence and it can take many different
forms ranging from
envy to cruelty you know he actually
lists off a number of sub vices that are
motivated by this fundamental anti-moral
incentive of
malice and then we get to compassion
here's something different is happening
egoism desiring what's good for you
right not really caring about other
people except insofar as it conduces to
what's good for you so you know loving
your children doesn't necessarily have
to come out of compassion if you view
your children as essentially like
stand-ins for you
or ways in which you show your moral
worth to society or something like that
that's still egoistic right
or you just happen to like hanging out
with them and it's it's enjoyable
malice is other oriented
rather than self-oriented the other is
the patient you are the agent and you're
trying to make them suffer in some way
compassion is also other oriented but it
desires
the good
for other people it desires wheel as he
says
and it also has to do with uh the other
person's woe alleviating it preventing
it
um lessening it in some
ways and he tells us a couple other
things that are very interesting about
us egoism he says
is boundless
left to its own devices
egoism as he says a little bit earlier
would say screw the whole world
so long as i get what i want and the
world indeed is in many respect a
conflict of incompatible egoisms who are
held in check what about malice he says
of this
um
goes to the limits of extreme cruelty
it's so it's not
boundless the way that egoism
potentially is
but it can go pretty far and
where it goes is somewhere bad
and then he says
compassion
goes to the length
of
nobleness
and magnanimity now this term
magnanimity if you think about it in a
aristotelian sense or perhaps in the way
that the stoics used it it typically
means rising above and not caring about
the trivial stuff
well
this is not exactly the same sense of
magnanimity here because compassion
could extend
down to the
very lowly and trivial so that's that's
important to keep in mind as well
um
so
we can also talk about the
actions and how we read them as i
pointed out just a little bit earlier
schopenhauer doesn't assume that we have
a kind of privileged insight into
everybody else's motives or incentives i
mean they could be lying about it if
they tell you they could be confused
about it
we can be confused about our own motives
but he does tell us
after bringing up again you know it says
in keeping with the previously mentioned
fundamental springs of all actions
egoism malice and compassion the motives
that are capable generally of moving men
and women can be grouped into three
general and principal classes one's on
wheel and others woe another's wheel and
then he says now if the motive of a
charitable action is not from the third
class
it must naturally belong
to the first or
the
second and he he actually says something
quite funny here so a lot of charity a
lot of doing good to other people is
motivated by egoism
you want to look good you want to feel
good about you know being a big giver or
something like that you want a tax break
whatever it happens to be but you could
even do it out of malice like you
give to somebody to annoy
their neighbor who you don't like
right you give a present to somebody and
it's very clearly uh present for them
but which is you know promoting their
their uh wheel
but it's supposed to inflict woe on
somebody else and so you know we can
have all sorts of differing motives we
need to look at the motivational
structures
rather closely in order to be able to
tell
what the
motive the probable motive of an action
is and so these are the things that that
schopenhauer thinks are
fundamentally
driving and motivating us with respect
to the actions
that we choose and their moral
evaluation on our part
you